欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好好久没有说这句话了
今天台股在创历史新高
来到了48601
但是今天的心情可能有一点无味杂陈
因为到了11点12点
台股就持续的往下杀
把涨点几乎全数吐回
留下了一个长达800点的上影线
中场只涨了80几点
所以大家会想说
是不是因为长假效应
还是应该怎么看呢
因为昨天晚上
美股的表现很厉害
而且是AI领军哦
MD Meta全数大涨哦
而他们大涨的理由
其实并不是新鲜事
而是关于AI的信心
市场的气氛全数回龙
所以今天这个长长的上影线
也许我们有一点点短暂的长假因素
但中长线来看
我们的反攻号角看来是已经
怎么样吹起来了
外销订单也在创下历史新高
台股的底气超级强
来欢迎今天的三位来宾好好讲解
第一位是AI达人蔡明翰明翰哥
AI达人告诉大家
800点的上影线
如果一进场就早盘进去的人
可能感受不好
但他要特别讲
今天真的叫做反攻好小的响起
因为是由美股的AI科技股来全面带动
今天汉策也正式的挂牌了
从汉策来看整体封策
就是叫做今年好明年会更好
到底还有哪些个股符合这样的条件
我们要有信心不要被常常上引线吓到了
明汉哥等一下来告诉大家咯
第二位是齐全王子张宁中
好齐全王子也要来讲咯
熬过了所谓的九月魔咒了
剩下最后一个礼拜了迎接光辉十月
现在外资的空单慢慢的回补
真的是一个好现象哦
那到底10月我们要来看哪些的股票呢
等一下也会独家帮你选
KD黄金交叉
中哥的独门绝学
再加上个股期的量增
这些都是一些好的盘面上的热门股
现在都
有的还没有创新高哦
可能也要跟着创新高哦
一定要好好的看起来咯
好第三位呢
是我们的基金医生志源哥
好今天你会有一个感受哦
怎么股票差距这么大
开盘一大堆涨停的
盤中一大堆掌停打開
尾盤雷一大堆翻黑
怎麼選
其實AI的氣氛回來
中小型股
台灣是最厲害的
可是高波動
高波動的話
用基金幫你一網打進
小資族就可以輕鬆入手
這個是大家最喜歡的
等一下來教大家囉
好 首先有請明漢哥
哇 今天的漲點
這個800多點
後來被沒收
我覺得大家的心情很複雜
因為今天一早盤
我是覺得好開心喔
一口气就创历史新高了
好没有关系
其实呢
这礼拜只有四个交易日
这个是一个长线的反攻号角
大家不要只看这几天
换测今天上市了
但你更看好的是
整体封测明年会爆发性成长
对我们先讲
这个所谓的涨点被没收
当然说台股位阶相对有不同
我们先回过头来再讲
为什么今天能够创历史新高
其实比较重要的关键点
就是昨天晚上
纳斯达克指数创高
费半出现大涨
所以今天市場信心就會比較好
科技類股昨天為什麼會強
兩大因素
第一個部分就是Muse
大家一直在講說
這個出來之後狀況不錯
Google或者是Apple的這個
所謂App的下載
它是免費的榜首
然後呢
然後外資就提到說
未來Meta可能會有
2000億美金的這個
所謂未來資金可能會慢慢的
有機會之前投那麼多了
等於說慢慢的要開始回收了
然後呢 所以昨天股價大漲了11%
那我覺得第一件事情
對我的觀點而言
我覺得比較大的重點
先不要管下載量
我們等一下會講
再講這個城市
確實我覺得有一個
比較代表性的意義
以前就是傳統AI
你可能你要什麼出國
他只是幫你行程排一排
現在他可以直接幫你把後面的這些所謂的下訂或購買的東西一次都幫你完成這是一個很大的一個跨越這我個人的感受另外一個就是在講油價下跌
那重點就是之前油的卡的關
那目前來講講到有輸油管的部分
轉向亞洲市場
所以在昨天來講
一天就有七艘的大型油輪
能夠運出來
所以油價就出現比較明顯的下跌
另外就是川普願意跟伊朗總統會面
我只要講一個概念
先講到這個MUSE meta的部分
到底是不是真的那麼厲害
我要給一個概念
就是MUSE部分
一週下載了73萬次
然後大概10天左右
就來到這個所謂點擊率的最上緣
DeepSig等於說當時一個禮拜
其實還有260萬次
而且他真的是不到兩三天就爬到頂
那OpenAI當時是一上市馬上見頂
當然數字當時沒有那麼大
其實我只要講一個重點就是Trade
其實它上市一個禮拜就超過1億用戶
但對於這些數字
我覺得憑良心講還好而已
這為什麼能夠漲11%
可不可以解釋一下
很簡單看一下
這是今年以來的漲勢
它加上昨天的11%
今年的YTD才漲12%
所以簡單來講
今年要不是有這根
它完全沒漲
再來我們再講
昨天就是油價跟美債殖利率都有走低
可以看到昨天有走低
所以導致納斯達克創高
可是長期而言
你會發現他們是走同向的
就是股價是往上走
在線殖利率往上
所以整件事情我個人覺得
昨天能夠創高跟新聞面一點關係
有沒有
我會覺得我們回過頭來
還是回到這個廢辦的圖
回過頭來那時候七月在下跌
每天都有不同的鬼故事
我也一直跟大家講
不要去聽那個
就真的是漲多拉回而已
後續自然就整理
那我之前整理的時候提到
所以相對來講
比較不
等於說比較大的壓力
就是廢半一直在
等於月線附近弱勢整理
那台股如果要獨自創高
有很大的壓力
之前都提到
如果它能夠站上季線之後
整個趨勢就會反轉
那昨天來講算是首度
應該說修正以來
首度站上季線
所以我覺得一定具有一定的意義
所以我覺得應該要偏向樂觀
後續來講應該就會慢慢的越走越高
回過頭來
台股為什麼今天會有這麼長的上影線
對比一下位階就知道
我們還是一個最強的市場
要等一下廢半
對 應該說我們中間的位階還是存在的
那我剛剛講的這段時間
我們在這裡休息
讓它多漲一點
讓我們中間的這個價差能夠收斂
絕對是正向
記得就是被辦站上季線
這個真的是有意義的
所以後續來講
應該說很明顯的資金有開始回籠了
所以對於無論是美股
或者是台股的部分
應該都要樂觀一些
等於META讓這個代理人AI
這件事情是有意義的
市場正向看待
氣氛回來 廢辦站上季線
這些都有意義
那我們今天台股的上影線
除了要等人家之外
可能因為長假
也有人說今天大家會賣股變現
好 明漢怎麼看
我覺得過往紀錄
在最後幾天亮縮
本來就是合理的現象
但絕對不代表會跌
那只是說今天就是上
因為大漲又爆量
所以相對的
會有一些人想要在
節前先拿一點回來
我覺得是合理
可是你看一下
就是這三年有AI以來
中秋節過後台股表現
其實憑良心講
它也是往上走
所以你真的要在節前
就獲利了解
我剛剛講了
如果你今天持股很高
我覺得沒有問題
但是如果你持股也不是很高
你現在要考慮的
剛剛提到過往經驗在劫後
他是漲的
然後現在等了那麼久
費半終於站上季線
對 然後這個時候
你突然要減碼
你應該考
如果你低持股
應該考量怎麼加碼
我覺得才是對的
那至於如果持股比較高的
劫前拿一點回來
我覺得合理
而且可以預期
再來的兩天成交量能
可能會持續縮減
我覺得是合理
除非這兩天的美股有大波動如果沒有 台股就應該量縮然後震盪的幅度會比美股小我覺得才是合理一樣問題就是這幾天我們的漲勢會不如美股
或者是他們下跌
我們跌幅也會比美股小一點
我覺得才是合理
除了中秋節後會正向之外
即將進入十月這第四季
我相信這大家知道的應該也很多
所以我個人覺得真的
在廢半站上這個季線之後
第四季的波段行情
我覺得機率是高的
雖然說今年已經漲很多了
可是整個架構來講
還是會維持多頭
還是一樣就是維持高持股
當然先決條件
你的資金要盡量往AI靠攏
從今天的盤勢
還是可以看得到
應該說第二季強勢的時候
或者是這一段
現在開始轉強的看到
資金就是一直往AI所謂的移動
反而不是AI的族群
其實即使今天上半場
指數大漲的時候
不見得能夠漲到你的股票
所以剛剛提到資金往AI靠攏
維持高持股
所以我還是建議要
這個四度的這個報股過節
我還是覺得不用太擔心
所謂的中秋節的問題
好 這次的明翰
跟前面幾次有點不一樣的是
有時候漲得比較多
因為今天創歷史新高
都會提醒大家
台股在世界第一強
這個是有點危險的
可是今天的狀況有點不一樣
因為費半納指都上來了
反而是覺得要迎接
第四季的好光景
是 台育店很特別
昨天台積電的ADR是收幾乎最高
可是我們今天卻是收最低
你覺得這其實也是好現象
對 我也覺得是好現象
之前我們來節目也給大家看到
這個所謂的台積電的所謂的溢價的狀況
就是這兩三個月以來不斷的下跌
那為什麼就是台股太強
一直在歷史新高附近震盪
完全跌不下去
但是台積電ADR有一個比較明顯的修正
現在距離高點還有接近10%左右
所以希望現在要看到
絕對不是台股趕快創高
現在要的是ADR趕快補漲
所以目前的角度ADR能夠大漲
那台積電沒有上去
我覺得是好現象
我希望的是ADR不要被這根所壓抑
通常他會看到台股今天開高走低
今天晚上ADR就容易修正
我是希望不要修正
繼續漲
然後台股一直都不要漲
讓這個預價差能夠拉開
對台股都是正向的
另外呢
今天可以看到
連發科的部分來講
確實還是相對強勢
也在創歷史新高
對 它很特別的
就是這些強勢族群有一個特色
就是2027年的EPS
都是大幅成長的
雖然聯發科今年的EPS沒有動
但是市場的均值都認為
明年會獲利會翻倍
所以股價的一個部分自然強勢
創意的部分就是
非常不可思議的公司
就是今年獲利成長八成
明年還可以成長130%
所以股價的部分自然有機會不斷走高
我覺得這個也都是數字會說話
另外新興的部分也算是表現很好
今年是因為基期低
所以EPS成長是三倍以上
明年還是有超過八成
我覺得都沒問題
之前因為這個所謂的
看到減掉的一個部分導致拉回
這幾天休息一段時間沒有太大動靜
自然還是會反應基本面而轉強
今天宰版三雄都很兇
台積電據說魏哲嘉在前兩天
遇到蔡立行跟他說
我們的股價會趕上聯發科
希望然後網友就說要向上趕上
不要聯發科向下趕上
應該不會因為兩個趨勢
因為剛剛提到兩個
明年的趨勢都還在往上
當然我憑良心講
我覺得他要趕上聯發科
是不太可能
因為股本各樣條件
另外就告訴他
確實漢測要掛牌狂飆
先講一件事情
最近因為他掛牌
所以導致這些所謂的
我們看到這些
探針
對探針卡感覺都蠻慘的
我跟大家講暫時的而已
所有看到探針卡利空
耳朵遮起來
千萬不要聽
真的基本面很好
純粹因為漢色的資金效應而已
持有者要一點耐心
他們的營收真的都很強
獲利也都很好
只是資金來講
就轉向休息一段時間的這個封測族群
那只是外資的報告
這要告訴大家說
為什麼現在的封測很好
是因為先進封裝的需求很強那從這個是所謂藍色是26 黃色是27年你可以看到26 27都還在快速成長當中
從輝達到博通超微
連發科在這裡
另外還有Mavelle之外
看到創意
所以你可以看到這些被點名的個股
他們需要大量的所謂的
我們剛剛講的先進封裝
代表他業績面非常強勁
那這些AI的先進封裝
到底誰提供的
這個是台積電是藍色的
黃色的就是非台積電
就是我們等一下會講的
這個晶圓電 日月光
另外Intel的部分也有提供
未來的部分
還會有台積電的Corpus的部分
也會加入陣營
所以看起來重點就是AI的需求
從探針卡一直到後段的
這些封裝的部分來講
都是正向的
所以這幾天持有這些探針卡的拉回
真的不要害怕
純粹是資金的效應
真的 我只能講
基本面很好
那這些個股來講
我們就幫大家挑選一些
封測的個股
那結論就是
AI 關聯度比較高的
就是有辦法跨入先進封裝的
還是日月光跟晶圓電
相對來講算是兩檔比較標準的個股
那以日月光來講
今年獲利增長快一倍
然後呢明年還有辦法增長五成
要跟大家概念
看到今年EPS成長96%
這是現在
年初的時候大概只有預估接近四成
所以代表他的
獲利一直以來都是優裕期不斷上修
所以不要擔心說
為什麼這裡96名年只剩五成
這未來都還有可能持續調整
最起碼他們的趨勢都還在
晶圓店也有一個比較特別要告訴大家
他今年獲利看起來沒成長
是因為去年他有一個一次性的業外
所以導致激起很高
其實他本業獲利
或者是你看到他的營收
成長其實是很強是沒有問題的
所以明年預估還有接近6成的EPS成長
所以這兩檔我還是覺得
比較中心的核心思想
另外聯軍的部分也可以留意
因為他是所謂的光通訊的封測
所以他比較特別
那我只要講重點就是
他的獲利成長也非常優秀
營收表現也不差
可是他有個缺點就是他的
透明度相對比較低點
我是講從法人的角度
所以他的報告少
然後訊息相對少
所以風險稍微偏高一點點
另外中高階半導體
雖然沒有到直接的整個
跟AI有直接相關
但還是有一些間接性
獲利也不錯
所以應該說如果你想要
買便宜一點的
等於說本益比相對比較低的個股
對 可以從這個角度出發
最後的部分就記憶體的部分
記憶體封測其實他們的獲利不錯
所以本益比也都不高
但是這個記憶體封測
可能他的走勢就跟記憶體族群
會有比較直接相關
他就不見得會跟著封測族群
所以可能投資人來講
要稍微拿捏一下
你自己比較喜歡的一個方向
新學系格都是非常好的公司
而且多少都有跟CPU也要接近
預程還有擅出型封裝
其實大家都多題材去發展
是 只是說 對
現在大家因為AI
現在已經第三年了
所以大家也都不斷耕耘
只是說比例的問題
現在相對而言
還是這兩家的比例相對比較高
簡單而言從去年底
開始台積電吃不下來
必須得留到外面之後
就是以這兩家吃到的比例相對比較高
慢慢的當然會往下延伸
只是這速度的問題
所以就目前角度
我還是覺得投資的方向來講
日月光 晶圓電相對來講
就是獲利比較穩健的個股
應該是比較不同的說
或者是反過頭來
如果你今天想買
這些所有價值的個股
你應該要選擇不是
封測熱的時候
就平常冷沒人要的時候
你可以減
這個時間點現在市場上資金進來
再轉強 你硬要切入
你就盡量選擇這種
相對比較穩健的個股
也許漲多到這邊可能會拉回
但是後續而言
大型個股明明比較不會害怕
你才能夠持續加碼
好 這個日月光 晶圓電
絕對是可以統包的
日月光是全世界第一大的封測股
晶圓電也算是前幾大的封測股
所以這邊的話
先選龍頭這段時間
就比較不會FOMO了
沒錯
好 這邊非常謝謝明翰
謝謝